buenos días desde cali valentín a la
ciudad trata de recuperar la normalidad
y tanto es así que la alcaldía ha pedido
que este lunes sea una jornada cívica
cívica de hecho acá destacar que el
propio alcalde jorge iván ospina va a
participar en una marcha pacífica que
trate de devolver la normalidad a la
ciudad después de varios días de bloqueo
que han dejado imágenes de
desabastecimiento en gasolineras pero
también en supermercados y bancos
las marchas comenzaron el pasado
miércoles 28 de abril y aunque sí que es
verdad que habido enfrentamientos entre
policía y manifestantes y altercados la
verdad es que la mayoría de
manifestantes han salido de forma
pacífica lo que también es verdad es que
como bien decías organizaciones de
derechos humanos y sociales han
denunciado que cerca de 1000 personas
han podido resultar heridas y más de una
decena de muertos no ante esto la verdad
es que no ha habido una respuesta del
gobierno pero sí que la defensoría del
pueblo ha celebrado una reunión en la
que han asegurado que van a seguir de
cerca todas las marchas y las acciones
policiales y por su parte la
procuraduría del estado ha asegurado que
la presencia de militares en las calles
no debería producirse louis porque
continuará el paro pese a la retirada de
la red
tributaria
para buscar esas claves creo que es
importante ver la minga la minga
indígena que llegó el domingo a cali y
que este lunes van a hacer una rueda de
prensa en la que van a analizar y
declarar informar cuáles son las
siguientes pasos con la duda que hay de
si finalmente querrán desplazarse a
bogotá sin embargo ya lo han asegurado
en un comunicado lo que quieren ahora es
la renuncia del presidente de ban duque
una sintonía similar a los manifestantes
nuestra experiencia estos días en las
calles nos ha hecho ver que que no es
sólo la reforma tributaria lo que ha
hecho que despierte esta ira en colombia
sino que también hay otros proyectos de
ley como la reforma de salud que nos
gustan entre los manifestantes u otras
quejas que es el aumento de la pobreza
también la reanudación de la expresión
con un beat fosfato para erradicar
cultivos de coca o también la sistémica
asesinato de líderes sociales que vive
el país
louis pues muchas gracias por toda esta
información estaremos muy pendientes de
lo que ocurra en las próximas horas en
colombia